to the Middle East now and three Israeli
soldiers who have been shot dead on the
Egyptian border the bodies of two were
found this morning while the third was
killed during a shootout with a gunman
an Egyptian police officer who's also
dead or joining me now from Jerusalem is
our Middle East correspondents Alistair
bunkel Alistar just give us further
details on this
around 8 30 a.m this morning at a border
post down on the Israeli Egyptian Border
in southern Israel the bodies of two
Israeli soldiers were found a man and a
woman they were found after they had
failed to answer Radio Calls to check in
during their shift Gathering guarding
the border and what then ensued was a
Manhunt for their killers and when a man
was identified he was surrounded by
Israeli military there was a gunfight a
third Soldier was killed as part of that
gunfight we understand uh some more
Israeli soldiers were injured in it and
the gunman himself was killed now he's
been identified as an Egyptian policeman
his role in it all is rather unclear one
of the reasons being that earlier on in
the morning in the middle of the night
around 2 30 a.m a major smuggling drug
smuggling operation was also foiled
drugs being taken from Egypt over the a
border wire that divides the two
countries that the Israelis have erected
in recent years primarily to stop either
migration or Islamic militants from
entering Israel but also a well-known
smuggling route so this major operation
took place in the middle of the night
now whether or not the deaths of the
Israeli soldiers were part of that and
they were killed by some of the
Smugglers is not yet clear a major
investigation has been launched the
Israeli military down in the South are
still looking to see whether there are
any other gunmen around that we're told
and when you sort of first hear this
obviously your thoughts turn to
potential tensions or conflicts between
the Israelis and the Egyptians they
fought wars in the past but that border
has been reasonably stable for some
decades now and although it was an
Egyptian policeman that was killed by
the Israeli military I'm told by Israeli
military sources that they are
coordinating with their Egyptian
counterparts that coordination is
ongoing it is good there is no
suggestion uh that it is anything beyond
perhaps a very very tragic incident but
the death of three Israeli military
officers is a very very significant
incident as well and I think as the
investigation goes on it will come
clearer whether or not it was as a
result of this attempted drug smuggling
or perhaps something else